vos journaux giraud plusieurs
départements du var je voudrais vous
parler de l'action que nous avons menée
en europe
pour les non initiés mais nos jeunes qui
sont dans les ehpad et qu'ils n'avaient
pas à l'époque du confinement la
possibilité de voir leur famille donc
que nous avons avec mon groupe
majoritaire un verre bien sûr nous avons
décidé d'acheter des tablettes tactiles
simple pour que les nos anciens puissent
s'en servir
tout naturellement je dois vous avouer
que nous sommes aperçus que entre les
soignants des parrains la samir est bien
tenu la personne âgée et bien un lien
social s'est créé et je crois que nous
devrions les uns et les autres
pensez à généraliser peut-être d'andorre
dans un autre contexte cette expérience
expérience qui à mon avis est une
expérience à wailly ci ne serait ce que
par rapport à l'heure des retours que j
ai directrices et des directeurs des
étapes
[Musique]